All right, it's time to play
Rock the Waffle House.
Normally, the jam served up
by Waffle House
come from a huge jar in the back
that needed to be replaced
months ago, but they've
been serving up musical jams
right under our goddamn noses.
Or earses.
Waffle House has their own
record lab... Oh, you know this?
Waffle House
has their own record label,
which they've had for 30 years.
They've been cooking up
hot songs like "Color Me Gone."
♪ Scattered, smothered, covered
and a cup of joe ♪
♪ Make it large, to go ♪
♪ Then there's no more highway
left to chase ♪
Yeah.
(cheering and applause)
This is the one table at Waffle
House that's having a good time,
as opposed to the other seven,
where someone's taking a nap
before their custody hearing.
Uh... now that we know
that America's favorite
breakfast home is releasing
such hot tracks,
let's help 'em out by coming up
with some new musical acts
Waffle House Records can sign.
In 60 seconds. And begin.
Yassir.
-Ghostface Grillah.
-Points.
-Yassir.
-Griddle Wayne.
Points. Nick.
Dixie Fried Chicken.
-Points. Yassir.
-(sobs)
Waffle Iron Maiden! Come on!
-(cheering) -Yeah,
they're-they're giving it up.
Points. Jenna Elfman.
AC/Decaf.
Points. Yassir Lester.
-Canadian Drake-on.
-Points.
Oh, the sweetest bacon of all.
Nick Thune.
The Links, with their hit song
"M-M-My Mimosa."
Yeah, points. Jenna Elfman.
The Rolling Scones.